[Musique]
bienvenue dans le duel des éditos votre
émission politique hebdomadaire
au sommaire j moins 100 avant la
présidentielle nos éditorialistes passe
en revue les candidats et leurs chances
lors de l'élection des surprises sont
elles encore possible l'élection est
elle déjà joué une campagne
présidentielle soit mikron sera t-elle
une campagne comme les autres
c'est le débat de la semaine alexis
poulin et jacques de guilbaut vous
livrons ensuite leur avis sur une actu
du monde d'après mais d'abord emmerder
les non-vaccinés jusqu'au bout la phrase
choc des manuels macron a fait trembler
les bancs de l'assemblée avec des
suspensions à répétition et une
opposition vont de vous je ne peux pas
cautionner athex qui a pour objectif
d'emmerder les français la
transformation du passani terre en passe
vaccinale s'avère de plus en plus
chaotique pour le gouvernement
alors faute politique ou déclaration
volontairement choquant d' emmanuel
macron le pass vaccinale une mesure
pertinente malgré un taux de vaccination
dépassant les 90% messieurs on attaque
cette actu des éditos avec une première
question cette stratégie du président
contre les non vaccinés n'est ce pas
finalement ce que veulent les français
vaccinés est exaspéré par bientôt deux
ans de crise sanitaire
bonjour jacques bonjour alexis non je
crois pas que les français soient aussi
bas qu emmanuel macron au point de
vouloir choisir la politique du bouc
émissaire
emmanuel macron a choisi les non
vaccinés comme étant les responsables de
tous ses échecs comme étant les
responsables de cette crise sanitaire
qui dure on le voit bien ce n'est pas
une épidémie non vaccinés le risque pour
les non vaccinés aujourd'hui c'est de
finir en réanimation et d'engorger
l'hôpital public qui est au cassé depuis
des années en fait de politiques de
rigueur et rien ne changera avec ce pass
vaccinale malheureusement oui mais il
n'empêche que quand on entend les
médecins en fait c'est devenu c'est une
crise public c'est plutôt une crise
hospitalières sont les médecins veille
se plaignent de ces engorgements comme
vous le dites et qui se trouve à devoir
soigner des gens qui n'auraient pas dû
soigner parce qu'ils sont pas vaccinés
et je pense qu'il ya une exaspération de
ce côté-là de l'hôpital qui est remonté
emmanuel macron s'en sert évidemment à
des fins politiques et c'est extrêmement
bien divisé sachant qu'il a oui 80 à 90%
des français qui le suivent là dessus un
peu moins sur le pass vaccinale
heureusement mais on est quand même à
plus de 60% des français qu'ils sont
favorables à l'instauration du parce que
oui alors mais ce qui est terrible parce
que on commente les mots d'un président
de la république qu'il n'aurait jamais
dû avoir jamais pu avoir un président de
la république française c'est une
institution c'est pas emmanuel macron
ces mêmes l'institution garante des
autres institutions et du droit et de
l'état de droit là avec ses déclarations
qui veut faire populo à l'idée c'est à
vous pourrez plus aller au café boire
des canons maintenant je veux emmerder
les non vaccinés c'est pas des mots
dignes d'un président de la république
c'est quelque chose qui aurait dû amener
une sanction immédiate celle de dire je
ne respecte pas un président qui ne
respectent pas l'ensemble du peuple
français or le problème c'est que
choisir la politique du bouc émissaire
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
dangereux parce que c'est diviser sur
des bases en plus totalement
fallacieuses les vacciner les
non-vaccinés sachant que le virus
circulera peu importe le nombre de
vaccins on voit bien que les variants
arrive et omicron le montrent les
vaccinés sont d'ailleurs plus poreux
omicron que les autres on est vraiment
dans quelque chose de l'ordre de la
politique dégueulasse excusez moi du
moment après tout le président entrant
merdé en choisissant de pointer du doigt
une minorité de la population française
et en la poussant devant la foule en
disant voilà allez-y
c'est eux les responsables oui je pense
que vous exagérez un petit peu il n'y a
pas de lynchage pour l'instant de non
vaccinés par des vaccinés dans la rue il
ya en revanche oui les gens qui parce
qu'ils ne subissent plus d'opérations
qui devait avoir à l'hôpital qui était
prévu parce qu'il ya des non vaccinés
qui viennent prendre leur place donc là
dessus non parce qu'il ya assez de place
à l'hôpital passer 2
sur 20 ans mais les nommez moi je suis
d'accord avec vous sur la méthode
qu'utilise emmanuel macron qui est
scandaleux surtout pour quelqu'un qui se
réclament du cercle de la raison qui est
censé être le l'homme plus pondéré
modéré à côté de tous les leaders
populistes qui l'entourent qui ne
peut faire des gens comme ça à qui
voudrait pas s'identifier et là ils
s'identifient sans doute parce qu'il est
en campagne électorale comme les vois
que ça fonctionne et qu'il a derrière
lui un électorat sûr et stable qui
veulent sortir de cette de cette
pandémie et ou qui ont peur de mourir et
ça ils ont tout à fait raison mais ou
pas peut-être qu'ils sont entre autres
points saillants en tout cas vu dans la
méthode avec laquelle il le fait par est
scandaleuse
le fond du problème existe quand même
pouvait pas faire comme s'il n'y avait
pas de souci est que yahvé passe les 10
% de français qui ne venaient pas poser
un problème au reste de la france parce
qu'il refuse mais je crois que les
choses fonctionnent non je crois que le
problème c'est les et c'est pas les 10%
non vaccinés c'est cette classe
politique qui depuis 40 ans à saboter
les services publics jean castex en tête
à et avec lui valérie pécresse aussi à
l'époque donc on peut y aller et marisol
touraine malgré la taille qui était dans
son cabinet enfin bref je vais pas faire
toute la liste mais gauche ou droite
depuis des années ont choisi sur les
conseils des cabinets de conseils de fer
l'hôpital de flux de réduire de faire
que des soignants en france soit les
moins payés d'europe de faire que ce
soit un métier finalement qu'il fasse
fuir plutôt que qui attire des talents
et des gens qui ont envie de servir la
communauté et on arrive aujourd'hui pour
masquer des années de politique indigne
à dire ah bah c'est la faute des dents
vacciner merci le coc vide ça permet
quand même de faire une magnifique
pirouettes et de et de se poser en
sauveur de la nation alors que c'est
tout l'inversé moi je suis pas oui je
suis pas tout à fait convaincu
- vous en tout cas je pense pas qu'il
soit seulement un problème d'hôpital qui
date d'il ya 20 ans avec un problème
réel il ya comme une partie de la
population qui ne veut pas entendre des
arguments raisonnables qui maintenant
sont trouvés il ya 10 milliards de doses
de vaccins dans le monde personne n'en
est mort ou alors très peu face à
fonctionne ce sont les mêmes qui ne
voulait plus pas se faire vacciner
qu'ils maintenant oui mais le vaccin ça
marche pas afin qu'il cherchait
justification a posteriori de leur refus
de se faire vacciner et de leur refus
d'adopter des mesures élémentaires pour
se débarrasser de cette de cette crise
est là dessus enfin voilà vers on a
parlé à l'assemblée nationale et je suis
pas tout à fait en désaccord avec ce
qu'il a dit et on va l'écouter il y à
les éloigner il y a les indifférents je
suis certain que nous arriverons à les
convaincre de se protéger et de protéger
celles et ceux qui les entourent et puis
il ya ceux pour lesquels aucun registre
rationnel ne peut être mobilisés ils
brandissent des grands principes ils
revendiquent la liberté mais leur combat
est minuscule et méconnaît profondément
les principes élémentaires pour vivre
ensemble pour faire société y compris
dans les périodes difficiles on a quand
même un ministre de la santé qui dit que
le combat pour les libertés est un comme
un minuscule c'est formidable
heureusement il ya l'opposition qui
étaient là et notamment jean luc
mélenchon qui a répondu au ministre des
rangs à l'assemblée
nous n'avons pas d'autres recours compte
tenu de ce qu'a été le débat en
commission et compte tenu de ce qu'est
le comportement général des membres du
gouvernement à l'égard de ceux qui ne
sont pas d'accord avec eux
pour vous obliger peut-être a présenté
pour la première fois un plan qui soit
vraiment un plan global nous étions donc
contre se passe sanitaire nous voici
contre le pass vaccinale parce qu'il est
100% inefficace
oui je veux dire qu'il est efficace mais
que propose la france insoumise de même
que propose le rassemblement national où
eric zemmour ou même les alertes pour se
substituer à symphatisants pour
l'instant eu aucune politique qu'ils
avaient opposé à emmanuelle acron et
pourtant on pourrait faire la liste de
toutes les erreurs qu'elle macron et son
gouvernement depuis deux ans rien
proposé il y avait la planification
l'idée d'avoir une agence nationale du
médicament ne pas laisser la fabrication
et les brevets aux laboratoires y avait
le roulement de la société y avait
plusieurs solutions mises sur la table
mais ça c'est un il faudrait pour ça
qu'il ya un débat démocratique vivant et
pas une parodie de débat où on veut
faire passer des lois la nuit à 5 heures
du matin en disant allez dépêchez-vous
parce que le président a décidé que
fallait aller très très vite le problème
il est là c'est que si emmanuel macron
ne s'était pas enfermer dans des
conseils de défense sanitaire a décidé
seul avec quelques gens choisis autour
de lui on aurait peut-être eu une
réponse un peu plus intelligente où les
responsabilités auraient été partagé or
depuis le début de cette crise on le
voit qu'elle est le l'effort des modèles
mcqueen ce gouvernement c'est de
désengager sa responsabilité surtout
hélas c'est magnifique le pass vaccinale
ça évite de rendre la vaccination
obligatoire et donc d'être responsable
in fine et s'il y avait une catastrophe
sanitaire et et de faire pousser de me
faire porter par dans la pression sur
les individus chacun vous êtes
responsable de vous vacciner mais en
plus d'être responsable
on vous force avec l'extorsion vaccinale
qui est ce parce vaccinale en aidant
portion actions et bien sûr puisque vous
ne choisissez pas quand j'entends
olivier vers en dire beaucoup de
français ont choisi la première
injection ils n'ont pas choisi ils sont
poussés et forcé par une politique qui
les force sinon ils sont débranchés de
la vie sociale
c'est une politique indigne l'italie a
choisi la vaccination obligatoire que
c'est plus de 50 ans l'allemagne va
choisir la vaccination obligatoire vous
avez plein de pays qui vont choisir la
vaccination obligatoire parce qu'ils
engagent leur responsabilité
là on a le nez responsable ni coupable
ni même pas président on a des gens qui
sont des manipulateurs machiavélique qui
utilise la politique du bouc émissaire
qui est scandaleuse oui elle est
scandaleuse mais il aurait fait voté
l'obligation vaccinale vous auriez aussi
pester et gueuler en disant on atteint
une liberté encore plus que ce qui est
le cas la veille encore plus des motifs
donc papa formation oui ils vont au fur
et à mesure ils font au fur et à mesure
en mentant je suis d'accord et en disant
que des choses qu'ils n'arriveront
jamais et qui arrive et puis hélas sur
le pass d'accès à louis le fait que ce
con de réclamer les députés de droite
notamment que ya une limite ça se passe
vaccinale qui n'a pas été
votée finalement est que le gardon
nathalie ça c'est un scandale on est
d'accord on n'a pas envie d'avoir un
pass vaccinale pour milan mais si
l'assise scandaleux mais voyez vous
inscrire que les oppositions à l'extrême
gauche à l'extrême droite joue aussi
électoralement c'est à dire qu'elle
voyait bien cave un grand pourcentage de
leur électorat
énervé par ça en a marre de oui de ses
obligations manifeste pour ses libertés
et ils se trouvent eux-mêmes prisonnier
d'une certaine façon et c'est là le
grand coup de génie de macron pas de
politique c'est de les rendre prisonnier
de cet électorat là et de les empêcher
afin de les forcer à danser d'un pied à
l'autre les salaires étant les plus
caricaturaux là-dessus qui à l'extérieur
disent qu'ils sont pas d'accord mais
vont voter quand même à l'assemblée
finalement bref ils sont prisonniers de
ce piège de macron une chose parce que
on entend christian jacob dire si si le
pas accès à leur bière mais rld et les
français je peux pas cautionner ce texte
bon les élèves vont concerner le texte
ils sont 200 députés avoir choisi
d'emmerdés des millions de francs le
faussement sage apporte là où ils sont
majoritaires mais il faut sortir je
pense des chiffres des petits sondages
se passe vaccinale il n'a pas de limite
dans le temps il est l'entrée dans un
nouveau monde un monde du contrôle
social à monde du crédit social parce
que une fois le colis de passer je pense
pas que cette idée de pas citoyen va
sortir par la fenêtre la preuve il n'ya
pas de limite de temps qui est déjà
imposée c'est une faillite des dde des
organes de contrôle et de conseil
conseil d'état conseil constitutionnel
la représentation nationale mais
derrière qu'est ce que ça veut dire et
on arnaque les français en pensant que
c'est pour une sortie de crise alors
qu'on est en train de les faire rentrer
dans une société de la vigilance oui sa
société vigeant c'est un terme qu'on
pouvait émaner de la con ça c'est vrai
après dire qu'on va arriver à un pass
citoyens ou encore être surveillées
comme en chine là je vous suis pas et je
pense que vous allez un peu vite en
besogne reste que d'accord avec vous
surtout cet accident n'était pas
nécessaire aujourd'hui
effet demain
meilleure cavalière et il n'y a pas
cette limite qui est insupportable on
espère que le sénat va peut être retoqué
un petit peu sur ses plans la
[Musique]
place aux débats de la semaine alors que
l'échéance approche petit état des lieux
des forces en présence à 100 jours de
l'élection prenez un emmanuel macron
largement en avance dans les sondages
mais toujours pas candidat a ajouté une
triangulaire à droite et à l'extrême
droite entre valérie pécresse eric
zemmour et marine le pen pour une 2e
place toujours pas fixé saupoudrez d'une
gauche toujours bien loin de l'union
dont rêvent certains et qui est en berne
dans les intentions de vote mélangez
bien avec une campagne sous menace du
variant omicron des meetings masqué
sûrement déserté et du tractage avec
distanciation sociale alors messieurs à
moins de 100 jours du premier tour en
trois beaux elle aura qu'il joue selon
vous cette élection
et bien cette élection aura un goût
assez répugnant je pense faire pour
rester polie et ne pas parler comme le
président de la république oui allait
très mal parti cette élection là pour
l'instant n'a aucune idée qui s'imposent
on voit des grands blocs un bloc très
énervé de droite et l'extrême droite qui
est presque majoritaire qui est fait 45%
emmanuel macron tout seul au centre et
puis une gauche façon puzzle qui
n'arrivent pas à poser à dépasser les 25
30 % toutes réunies oui c'est clair bah
moi je veux parce qu'elle n'aura pas le
goût vanille fraise mais qu'elle aura un
goût de merde pour parler comme le
président du coup on le voit d'ailleurs
avec cette campagne qui commence avec
ces mots indigne d'un président de la
république à vouloir montrer du doigt
une minorité de la population française
on aura ensuite d'autres minorités qui
seront montées du doigt j'imagine aucun
débat de fond finalement sur le modèle
de société sur ovale états qu'ils sont
aussi les pouvoirs au niveau local on a
des mères à qui s'organisent en disant
ce serait bien aussi qu'on reprenne un
peu le pouvoir dans les territoires qu
on compte organise une société autre que
cet état surgonflé centralisée avec un
présidentialisme totalement critique on
est arrivé vraiment a une limite dans la
vème république j'aimerais qu'on ait des
débats de fond or on voit que la gauche
est empêtré dans des débats de
candidature alors est-ce qu'il faudra un
candidat unique il y en aura pas un faux
pas rêver ça ne dépassera pas beaucoup
les 10% avec chance et puis la droite
des calculs des petits calculs de
boutiquier à savoir qui va aller dans la
maison commune des brêles macron qui va
essayer de sauver l air et que fait
zemmour évidemment dans ce jeu là c'est
assez terrible pierre emmanuel macron
qui regardent en rigolant en continuant
de manipuler les citoyens un sou je vous
aime g après avoué 10 je vous emmerde
c'est quand même un président formidable
et malgré ça il reste haut dans les
sondages c'est à n'y rien comprendre
bref non c'est enfin ça comprendre qu'il
ya un électorat qui a besoin d'être
rassurée qu'on est un pays qui est de
plus en plus vieillissant et c'est un
électorat bourgeois qui a peur pour ses
privilèges en train de vie tout
simplement que les manuels maquereau et
le seul pour l'instant à rassurer même
si une valérie pécresse essaye de jouer
dans la même cour que lui est à peu près
le même programme ses terres on voit
assez peu de différence est là tu la
gauche a raison aux médias le maquereau
qui est partie à l'origine du parti
socialiste est devenu quasi totalement
un président de droite fin de droite en
tout cas de la droite que j'ai de moi
mais en tout cas la droite libérale on
peut dire et le président oui des plus
riches de la théorie du ruissellement et
de tout va bien se passer économiquement
parce que je suis là en plus je suis
président de l'europe je vous ai fait un
show événement égotiste avant noël vous
raconter j'ai appris voilà qu'il avait
tout appris et la finale est pour
montrer d'ailleurs quinze jours après
qu'il n'avait pas appris grand chose en
tout cas sur son amour des français et
le mépris qui peut leur portée mais il
est fort il arriva à segmenter vous
regardez tout le tout la population
française toutes les classes d'âge
toutes les classes socio politique qui
fait à peu près le même score chez tout
le monde un score de 25 % fait entre 20
et la santé ce sac ne bouge pas et il
est voilà il celui qui a coupé part du
gâteau à son profit pour l'instant c'est
quand même impressionnant parce que
c'est un président qui sort avec un
bilan calamiteux qui a une équipe auteur
phare entre les ministres qui parodie
les humoristes ou les influences euse
qui maltraitent les français kiki les
insultes qui les méprise et pourtant 25
% sont prêts à reprendre des coups de
fouets c'est impressionnant et puis il
ya aussi quelque chose qui joue en
faveur des macros et c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça qu'ils avancent aussi vite sur
le pass vaccinale etc c'est qu'il
pourrait se positionner en vainqueur du
coc vida on sait que ça potentiellement
coûté l'élection aux états unis à donald
trump cette crise du comité or là on
voit qu'elle phagocyte totalement la
campagne électorale qui va mettre des
jauges qui va respecter davantage les
règles sanitaires que les autres comment
ça va se passer et on ne parle donc un
autre sujet c'est ce qu'on disait enfin
cesser un proprement une campagne qui
n'existent pas jusqu'à présent ou
vraiment très loin qui va être
dématérialisé alors jean-luc mélenchon à
ces hologrammes il y aura dès maintenant
ils l'arrêtaient l'odeur même dans ses
meetings vraiment motorama
c'est pour savoir quelques vides ou pas
c'est ça sans doute fait wind en vue
d'assurer les des gens qui se vantait au
mois de septembre comme eric zemmour a
raison d'avoir réussi à imposer des
thèmes dans la campagne sous
l'immigration de la sécurité de
islamiste a nettement derrière reconnais
chez lui ont disparu là en deux mois
depuis début décembre
sont plus là et le co vie de serre est
imposé et ça devient oui le seul le seul
propos et comme beaucoup de ce que j'ai
l'air beaucoup de candidats sont pris
entre leur base qui est très anti
système donc menti vax ou anti passe
sanitaires et une base qui gronde et de
l'autre côté un besoin de sérieux
affiché dans cette gestion de crise ils
sont pris entre les deux aimée de la
cruz qui est lui le grand ordonnateur de
ça les a pris à son piège et à les
empêcher de sortir de ce de ce sujet
qu'il maîtrise lui puisque ces 1000km
être de toute façon et en essayant de
montrer qu'il est celui qui a sauvé la
france comme vous le dites et puis alors
il ya le problème des meetings
politiques aussi puisque c'est des
moments quand même où on peut avoir les
médias mobiliser les troupes et là il ya
les jauger les questions des jeunes
alors on a d'un côté valérie pécresse
anne hidalgo et emmanuel macron et la
reine qui vont appliquer parce
sanitaires et jose on va avoir yannick
jadot qui va restreindre la capacité
d'accueil il avait déjà commencé lors de
ses meetings précédents et puis à ceux
qui refusent les jauges et les contrôles
du pass eric zemmour jean luc mélenchon
qui distribuera des masques ffp2 et
marine le pen donc déjà là on voit un
sujet clivant sur la façon de gérer
cette campagne mais on voit bien que
c'est là encore les meetings politiques
sont devenus des moments de
communication des mises en scène qui ont
davantage le but d'être filmé plutôt que
d'être vécue donc les choses finalement
ça va pas changer grand chose si on
envoie un parti comme l'as raismes qui a
déjà du mal à y inclure des salles oui
et surtout emmanuel macron qui a la télé
toute la journée pour d'autres raisons
soit pour faire son bilan en décembre
soit pour parler de sa présidence du
conseil de l'europe n'a pas besoin
finalement de ses mines il a très peu il
est déjà candidat en campagne avec les
instruments de l'état ce qui reste
encore un scandale depuis assez
longtemps dans la république française
c'est à dire à quel moment il peut
commencer à faire un président sortant
on peut commencer à faire campagne avec
les instruments là c'est pas que le cas
d'emmanuel macro mais là il s'en sert
parfaitement bien et on va entendre
parler que lui par tous les médias tous
les moyens pendant les trois mois qui
viennent il a pas besoin finalement
d'aller faire des meetings sachant que
son électorat n'est pas si populaire que
ça en plus ce n'est pas forcément non
avec dora qui se déplace dans des
meetings à assen jour de l'élection il
ya quand même
une inconnue assez énorme et je pense
que c'est peut-être ce qu'il n'a pas vu
venir un imac rond quand ils emmerdent
les français c'est les abstentionnistes
ceux qui d'habitude ne se mobilisent pas
pour voter peut-être que cette année en
2022 on va avoir une surprise avec des
abstentionnistes qui vont retourner dans
les urnes s'il ne sont pas empêché parce
qu'ils n'ont pas le pass on verra
comment ça se passe là encore conseil
constitutionnel gérald darmanin sont en
train de de voir avec les différents
partis comment organiser les modalités
de cette élection en disant qu'elle aura
lieu et qu'elle ne sera pas d'égalé et
qu'elle aurait lieu dans les meilleures
conditions ça c'est les promesses inde
emmanuel macron mais on voit bien là
aussi qu' il ya une vraie campagne qui
peut se faire sur cette question des
abstentionnistes à savoir cette fois ci
c'est important voter et dès le premier
tour et on pourra avoir une surprise un
deuxième tour où deux candidats seraient
présents qu'il n'était pas du tout des
candidats poussé par les sondages où lé
mexique et par principe de ce soir qui
chez qui vont les abstentionnistes et
s'ils vont comme un seul homme vers un
candidat sera les draguer ou est-ce
qu'ils sont dispersés je pense qu'on a
il ya déjà une baisse de l'abstention
par rapport à récemment lorsqu'un eric
zemmour a pris une partie des
abstentionnistes jean luc mélenchon
aussi marine le pen assure son sont
bloqués elle mais pour l'instant il n'y
a pas de candidat antisystème parenti
gestion la crise sanitaire comme un
filippo ou quelqu'un d'autre qui a
réussi à mobiliser ces gens sur son nom
comme naguère des gens n'avaient pas
réussi à mobiliser sur les gilets jaunes
pour l'instant ça fonctionne pas sur ce
principe là et on vous dit les
abstentionnistes c'est pas justement
quelque chose qui peut être agrégées par
un une idéologie politique ou un parti
c'est des gens extrêmement disparates
qui vont pas se retrouver sur une
personnalité comme c'est le cas pour
d'autres thématiques donc c'est très
difficile mais il faudrait qu'ils se
trouvent un candidat qui ont merdé menu
et le maquereau qui est emmerdé les
français candidats pour se venger et
qu'il y ait des chances de gagner deux
points si on voit pas trop partir les
emmerdeurs oui c'est bon vous pouvez le
dans ses allées fier si vous voulez
aller peut devenir président voilà
partie des emmerdeurs d'emmanuel mac
mais
oui il peut lire cette surprise là moi
j'y crois assez peu et je pense que
depuis le début la 2d sondages depuis
presque un an maintenant c'est moi il ya
des blocs qui reste fixé à l'intérieur
de ces blocs ça bouge par exemple entre
marine le pen eric zemmour et valérie
pécresse mais on reste sur 45 droite
extrême droite 25 centres et puis le
reste à gauche à moins qu'une
candidature de gauche
efface toutes les autres et les fédère
derrière elle je vois pas comment ça
peut ça peut bouger la gauche
aujourd'hui il ya une candidature qui
est devant dans les sondages
systématiquement c'est celle de jean luc
mélenchon avec un ordre de disparaître
bien sûr hidalgo monde bourbon qui ne
fait plus campagne clairement yannick
jadot qui est loin derrière on ne
l'entend même pas sur le nucléaire qui
serait une énergie verte
par décrétées par l'union européenne
enfin il ne fait pas non plus vraiment
campagne on a l'impression qu'il ya un
flottement et puis il ya la primaire
populaire qui s'est engouffrée dans ce
flottement pour pousser d'une certaine
façon christiane taubira comme la
sauveuse une candidature de gauche mais
se veut aussi de ce qui reste du parti
socialiste à voir si ça marche arrière
des sondages qui la donnent plus haute
que 6 % dota 2 % l'effet taubira on
verra puisqu'elle est censée prendre la
parole et dire si elle se présente ou
pas à la mi-janvier donc c'est la
semaine prochaine mais clairement cet
attentisme dessert ce camp à cent jours
des élections je passe il n'y a pas de
miracle en réalité non et en plus la
candidature taubira qui à mon avis
n'aura pas lieu et qui est une illusion
va encore plus ridiculisé cette gauche
qui aura fait croire que fin janvier ou
début février se trouvera un candidat
deux ou trois mois avant l'élection il
serait absurde et qui viendrait
rassembler tout le monde est elle donc
je pense que ça va faire un flop à celle
que c'est juste une illusion encore pour
un mois pour des gens qui sera peut-être
on va être sauvée par savoir se servir
jean luc mélenchon qui peut bénéficier
justement de cette
division du ps de ce qui reste du parti
socialiste à dire moi ça fait des mois
que je fais campagne je suis toujours à
8% aidez moi à ça c'est ce qui reste il
est le vote utile de la gauche ont
annoncé aujourd'hui donc il peut il peut
le devenir c'est ce qui s'est d'ailleurs
essaie de faire mais de l'être au second
tour
est loin brillant par son fruit
direction le monde d'après alexis poule
a et jacques de guillebon vous apportent
leur éclairage chaque semaine sur une
information qui pourrait faire
l'actualité politique de demain
commençons par vous alexis selon vous
quelles infos mérite cette semaine un
coup de projecteur
mais à une info importante après le vote
du pass vaccinale c'est la mobilisation
du 8 janvier
alors il ya bien sûr florian philippot
on en parlait qui essaient de
capitaliser sur les antilles parce
qu'ils souhaiteraient une union sacrée
et il a du mal à amener d'autres leaders
politiques autour de cette union sacrée
parce que c'est florian philippot il a
les patriotes sont partis et s'il a des
personnalités comme l'avocat division et
d'autres les autres politiques regardent
ça plutôt de loin chacun essayant d'être
le leader de ce mouvement anti passé
pourtant je pense que ça dépasse la
politique politicienne il y aura du
monde dans la rue j'imagine celui
janvier mais ça ressemble un peu
malheureusement un baroud d'honneur la
rue n'est pas la solution face à ce
passe vaccinale ce qu'on va sans doute
devoir c'est une désobéissance de chaque
instant le fait que déjà les
restaurateurs ne contrôle plus les
passes c'est fatigant et que cette
société de la vigilance et du contrôle
des français par les autres français ne
marchera pas simplement par fatigue et
pourtant il ya besoin de montrer dans la
rue avant le vote au sénat que ces
millions de français qu emmanuel macron
emmerdes eh bien ils font honte ils sont
des citoyens comme les autres et ne sont
pas des citoyens de seconde zone oui
bien sûr ce ne sont pas des citoyens de
seconde zone mais je pense pas qu un
florian philippot et les épaules et le
crédit pour fédérer autour de sa
personne et de créer une union sacrée
surtout qu'il a quand même dit beaucoup
de bêtises depuis plusieurs mois à des
fins à ces démagogues en général et on
voit pas d'autres d'autres personnalités
de poids qui voit se joindre à lui ça va
on va lui faire comme les gilet jaune
s'est toujours refusée c'est d'avoir une
erreur je suis d'avoir des chefs et
finalement ça se sait se dissout parce
que c'est un message qui est uniquement
destinée rester à la russie qui remonte
nulle part et qui ne changent pas le nil
à vis des français ni l'avis du
gouvernement a fortiori
malheureusement mais bon ça a le mérite
de montrer que il ya du monde derrière
c'est 6 millions voire plus de français
emmerdé par mails macro moi ce dont je
voulais vous parler cette semaine c'est
le petit jeu qui se passe à droite et à
l'extrême droite c'est à dire que donc
le candidat eric zemmour qui fait
beaucoup de bruit il ya quelques mois
n'a pas de parti faquins partie en
construction d'après des qualifs n'a pas
d'élu est donc un gros problème c'est de
trouver ses 500 signatures qui est un
gros problème pour tout le monde mais
encore plus pour lui sachant d'où il
vient et sachant qu'il est assez peu de
pluie et qu'il en plus du mal à parler
au maire aux élus locaux qui sont pas
trop c'est plutôt quelqu'un de des
métropoles disons
et donc qui ça peut avantager de l'aider
à voir ces signatures c'est les
républicains puisque en fait eric
zemmour vient pour l'instant prendre
beaucoup plus sur l'électorat de marine
le pen et l'empêcher d'être au second
tour que sur l'électorat de valérie
pécresse pour l'instant même s'il prend
un peu chez pécresse et pour l'instant
c'est valérie pécresse qui s'en sort le
mieux même si les sondages donnent
parfois égalité mais elle est quand même
au dessus et en fait grâce à eric
zemmour elle veut se retrouver au second
tour face aux médias macron ce qui
aurait été impossible dans un cas où il
y aurait eu qu'un seul candidat de
l'extrême droite soit marine le pen ou
quelqu'un d'autre et qui ferait au moins
25% et autres un peu de chance pour
valérie pécresse donc l'union sacrée
elle c'est de ce côté là plutôt n'arrête
ces réunions visent non par dessous la
table oui c'est ça des républicains qui
a priori des instances et républicains
qui ont dit à leurs petits maires ou
alors petits élus locaux vous pouvez
donner votre signature eric zemmour on
viendra pas vous vous emmerdez puisque
c'est le mot de la journée après ça donc
vous avez toute licence pour le faire en
gros a les yeux on vous couvre et dont
vous pouvez donner vos signatures eric
zemmour parce qu'en fait on a besoin
qu'il se présente pour nous permettre
d'être au second tour assez très
machiavélique c'est très politique armée
c'est selon diverses informations venues
du parti ce qui est en train de se
passer dans le cadre du monde d'après
est-ce que ce moment est mourant qui est
une une bouffée médiatique incroyable
lors de ce lancement de campagne on voit
que ça ça se tasse un peu est ce qu'il
ya un après la campagne présidentielle
est ce qu'il y à l'envi de créer un vrai
mouvement une recomposition de la droite
où est ce que au delà de cette campagne
présidentielle eric zemmour retournera à
ses livres je pense que lui retournera à
ses livres et que son parti sera pas
assez structuré pour avoir des députés
il faudrait le seul truc c'est que ça
peut faire exploser marine le pen et
dégager la le terrain pour quelqu'un
d'autre l'élection suivante voilà mais
on en reparlera de semaine prochaine oui
et peut-être les mois prochains
également après l'élection merci lexis à
bientôt c'est la fin du duel des éditos
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur notre site rt france point tv
et en podcast sur toutes les plateformes
vous pouvez également réagir dans les
commentaires et sur les réseaux sociaux
via le hashtag ldd eux à la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau duel des et
vitaux
[Musique]